foreign
let's
go to Justin in Green Bay what's up
Justin
uh not much on my lunch break talking to
you dude that's pretty rad way to go man
your lunch break
well when you punch in at four in the
morning ah I see what you did there
you're one of those guys that worked
hard for a living what's that like is
that is that cool
well two jobs going to school for
mechanical engineering yeah I'm kind of
going all the time bro you're getting it
man so what's up
um I'm having problems with my I'm
raising my 12 year old daughter by
myself since she was five when her mom
decided
um her mom just kind of decided she
couldn't be a mom oh man
um she still has visitation
but it's rare like maybe once or twice a
year um she lives over in Detroit now
um and actually that comes back to it
when we were just over there two three
weeks ago she talked to her mom to talk
to me because she wanted an iPhone
and it's a question she's brought up
before and I told her no you don't need
an iPhone you don't even need a phone
phone but I need to get a hold of you
sometimes so talk text take pictures
that's all it's good for
um
and I asked her kind of
why did you go to your mom she's like
well I don't want you to get mad at me
if I'm not gonna get mad at you you just
ask and I say no
and she did it again with another friend
of mine went to her and then had her
come with her so she could quit
gymnastics
um she's been in it for seven years
and she's very very good she's just
struggling because she's at a new level
where they're harder on her they're kind
of pushing her and she's not taking to
it well plus she's a preteen
so I don't know what to do with her
going to other people saying I'll get
mad at her when it's just I tell her no
and I tell her why and it's like she
doesn't like the answer
hmm
do you get frustrated
less than I used to I used to be kind of
angry everything was thrown on me
um after the custody I almost lost my
house I had to fight to hang on to that
I'm coming out of the that's why I'm
going to school
I don't yell at her anymore
um I used to
um one thing you said a long time ago
was yelling is trauma and that kind of
Hit me hard because I grew up in a
household where I got yelled at a lot
yeah
so I stopped yelling I do get frustrated
because she is 12. 12 year old kid yeah
I got one too and yeah the frustrating
is part of the game
um
have you dealt with the fact that your
wife looked at you and said I'd Rather
Have Nothing than you
actually get along very well now
um that's fine you've made peace with
that have you dealt with that
I think so okay where does your rage
still come from
because here's the thing that a lot of
dads do we quit yelling
we quit hitting the wall
but we don't deal with the rage
and it just sits in our chest like a
nuclear reactor and our kids absorb it
they breathe it
and so we trade we stop an overtly
abusive Behavior which is great
but we are not a place for a child to
come rest
what I see your daughter doing is
actually really healthy she's trying to
connect with you and her body's telling
her that you're not safe
okay not because you're saying no I tell
my kids no all the time all the time
my guess is she's put a GPS pin and this
guy used to yell this guy her body has
created an ecosystem where you're not
safe in it
have you ever taken her out for
breakfast and said I used to yell out
I'm so sorry I'm never gonna yell again
I actually do that a lot had that has
that guy I apologize she she says I know
you don't yell you raise your voice when
you need to but you don't yell awesome
you're not angry
she you know I
tell her I love her she says she loves
me back she talks to me about everything
when she comes home from four hours of
gymnastics she's just comes home from
school and talks to me talks to me about
her friends and all that but it seems
like the things that I
say no to
it's almost like I'm
she's trying to get somebody else to get
on her side nah dude you know who did
that probably your wife
your daughter's 12. yeah she's just
pushing boundaries to see if they're
gonna hold
I wouldn't lose one second of sleep of
that in fact that's pretty admirable
because here's why
um you told your kid no you gave her a
reason
she uh didn't go in her room and slam
the door she went and found another
person to talk about how she feels
that's the that's the Baseline for being
well is having other people right it's
awesome and yeah it's up to you to not
get emotionally reactive when she comes
at you with three of her friends and say
Here's why she should have a phone and
you can smile and say y'all are really
brilliant we'll do ice cream but no
phones well played or I'll even tell my
son he'll be like hey Dad on the way
home let's just go ahead and get ice
cream because and I'll just look at him
and go well played man no chance and he
just like I'm not gonna get mad at 12
year old for being 12 year old
yeah and this is hard because you've
been her everything because you had to
be and you're a good man
but you can't be her everything forever
one of the greatest gifts my dad gave me
um I was a young kid and he was a he was
a homicide detective and then literally
over a weekend he quit and became a
minister at a big giant Church in
Houston
and he said this to me and I didn't get
how big of a deal it was until I got
older
but he said you are never going to be
able to hear about your our faith from
me anymore I'm your minister now and I'm
also your dad you're not going to listen
please find other men in this building
that you can trust
who will speak life into you and at the
time I was a kid I was like okay
whatever dude guys who cares what dad
say dads are morons right
um
when you're when you're 12 or 14. and
now that I'm older to think about my
kids and and now I'm hyperintentional
dude you find other people you talk to
that person you talk to that person I
love it I think it's great
it's it's not a you're you're putting
adult uh what's the you're putting adult
thoughts and feelings and motives into
the heart and mind of a 12 year old
is that fair
a little bit do y'all sit down and talk
about hard stuff like boys and periods
and stuff
[Music]
[Laughter]
she she kind of floored me with the
first boyfriend while we were cleaning
her room one day so that was fun
dude that's so good that she trusts you
man
just kind of walked away for a second
why
because I was I was so afraid of that
coming up being a single dad raising a
girl and knowing what little
butt heads little boys can be
even the good ones are turds man
um
it's so great that she felt safe enough
to do that with you
that's awesome
and it's it's also
like
you have an incredibly important role in
her life
and that's to tell her that she's
beautiful and that she's brilliant
and if she she'll allow it don't force
it but if she'll allow it to put your
hands on her face as often as possible
put your hands on the back of her neck
underneath her hair as often as possible
hug her as often as possible you don't
have to say anything
yeah
that's something I've very much tried to
do so I give her a hug I tell her she's
wonderful she's smart she's talented
she's funny and I get that smile yes and
I feel she hears me and I just watch her
lighten up and it makes my entire day
yes
and can I tell you one other thing to
balance
not saying this is you at all it's just
a common thing for folks who have
experienced what you've experienced is
that 12 year old will take on rightly or
wrongly
they'll take on making sure dad's okay
that's not her job and don't ever let
her fall into that role that I gotta
make sure dad's not mad I gotta make
sure dad's happy I gotta make sure
because she can't carry that she's still
trying to figure out what she did that
was so bad that Mom left her
and that demon will haunt her for years
right
I know I I she's the first couple years
are very hard
um when we left last time she started
crying but she kind of got over it quick
it's
after almost eight years just kind of
I don't want to say she accepts that she
hates it but
she kind of knows how it is and I see it
hurt her and I try and do everything I'm
at every gymnastics meets when she was
in bowling league I was there all the
time when she tried softball I was at
every game I ended up coaching so so let
her find her path
letter finder met her own road map
and
um there's a fine balance and I think we
did a Show recently about that there's a
fine balance between I'm going to make
you keep going until the season's over
till the support until this season is
over of this
um but if we if you're done at the end
I'll honor that but you're going to do
something you have to do something right
I gave her that good for you good for
you I gave her that you can be done at
the end of the season and but you will
be doing other stuff you will not be
sitting at home there you go that's good
I hear about it every summer I don't
want to practice oh but two weeks in I
did this I did that okay and that's just
being a dad good for you for not letting
a 12 year old's feelings run your
household that's awesome hey can I tell
you sounds like you're doing a great job
man
thank you I I worry a lot it's not easy
that's right none of this is easy
um
I yeah dude parenting is just sprinting
across a live wire without a net and
then with people shooting at you just
for fun right you're doing a great
you're doing a great job
and I I bucket a great job like
um I care about my kid I bucket a great
job like
um
I've got things I got to work on so I'm
gonna stop doing those things I'm gonna
keep working on those things
um and I'm Gonna Keep seeking wisdom man
and you're doing all three of those
things I'm and so I'm just grateful for
you here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
send you all the questions for humans
cards okay and all right set up a reg
here's what we're looking for we're not
looking for the perfect boyfriend
conversation
we're not looking for the just the right
pamphlet that's going to let us sit down
and talk about periods because Mom is
not around
we're looking to create an environment
where she feels so safe she can have
those conversations
and it sounds like y'all are there
as I just upped the ante with my 12 year
old
and I did something as much as
um make a list of the movies I wanted to
see before he he's gone here's a list of
things I want him to have done
whether that's change a tire tie a tie
you know dress a deer like whatever I
got some Texas things in there I gotta
have but what like what are these things
that I want to be a part of with him
that I can be intentional about and one
of those is just being able to have a
conversation and enjoy the silence and
so I'll send you all the cards man and
set up a regular breakfast with your
kids up a regular dinner take her on a
date once a week whatever that is and
instead of talking bad about the boys
they're gonna be dating her someday
let her experience
that boy is some knuckle-headed idiot at
middle school or high school kid is
gonna have to he already broke up with
her for no reason so I heard about that
too
well I know people we can find him we
can find him no but listen you want to
build you want to her to feel so safe
with you and so loved and so beautiful
and so brilliant when y'all are out on
your dates that some knuckleheaded high
school kid doesn't stand a chance
doesn't have a chance
she's look at his stringy mustache and
his mom's to used Camry and just be like
what in the world I'd really go to a
movie with my dad he's funnier he's
cooler
and he's got way more money than this
kid
right you want someone's gonna have to
really be special
and we're building a relationship there
I'd also encourage her
to have some adult women in her life
that are in your area
that you trust maybe from like school or
from your local church or whatever
wherever you get connected
and encourage her to make relationships
there
encourage her to have people to talk to
that may not be you the conversation
might go like I know you get nervous
sometimes around me talk to somebody I
would love you to talk to me
but I'd rather you talk to somebody than
talk to nobody right and if you help
curate some of those relationships
um man that gives your kid just an
entire safety net of people who love her
but man you've you're making the best of
a messy situation brother and I'm
honored to be a fellow dad with you on
this wild Journey we're on man
congratulations